[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission où ça découvre la
Réunion ensemble vous allez pareil alors
allons-nous
comment
[Musique]
il parle pas moins les misérables alors
la commune de Sainte-Rose
parasol et nous nous ça découvre le
sentier des laves allez allons-nous
je suis en train de regarder justement
tout ce qui est lié aux espèces
indigènes exotiques donc là on peut se
rendre compte qu'en fait on est dans un
espace qui est assez préservé sur une
colonisation de coulée de lave donc par
rapport à la végétation qu'on a en place
on a également malheureusement justement
des des touffes voilà de végétation qui
sont exotiques et qui viennent perturber
donc le milieu je veux dire de
renaturalité donc ici vous trouvez en
fait sur la partie donc la partie en
forêt domaniale et départementaux de
Manial voilà de l'enclos du Grand Brûlé
donc là en fait on cible des zones qui
sont intéressantes et on vient lutter en
fait contre les espèces exotiques
pour profit voilà des espèces endémique
indigènes parce que du coup là nous
laissions
une coulée de volcan et la et du coup
bah la ville a reprend vie alors ouais
ça reprend en fait comme au salon là
combien de temps la mettre là ça fait ça
fait déjà bon peu de temps ça fait déjà
par exemple les voies de remparts comme
ça ça facilement 70 entre 50 et 60 ans
donc le département c'est en fait qui
sont financières voilà des travaux et
donc nous en fait on organise le en tant
qu'agent de terrain voilà on appelle ça
en fait des des ACI des aires de contrat
intensif ou des pop et c'est pas place
sont mis justement on fait travailler
nos ouvriers donc on définit des anneaux
GPS donc ces zones là et on vient je
sais pas moi j'ai 0,5 ou un hectare donc
souvent c'est 100 m sur 100 m et sur
cette zone là en fait on va intervenir
donc ici on va passer là vous voyez donc
on va dégager par exemple à la ce ce va
quoi on va les couper par exemple vous
voyez cette tige là de fil à eau qui
viennent en fait embêter dans la partie
somitale voilà le bois de rempart
revenir couper et comme ça on va pouvoir
créer une régénération naturelle de la
forêt en tout cas moi je vais continuer
sur le sentier des larves ok bon
l'agréable ou pas ah les gaillards
[Musique]
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des dents derrière Elena la
montagne soleil
[Musique]
mais la réunion nous les larmes bonjour
bonjour monsieur dame comment allez
bonjour madame le bien bonjour ça va
bien alors
est-ce que l'importance hein
d'accord
faut pas courir il y en a plein ça fait
plus calé tout le temps devant l'écran à
9h le meilleur écran
à tout et voilà parce que sinon ça si
c'est pas une expliqua qui savent
expliquer
un petit peu sur durant cette randonnée
alors pendant la randonnée laver les
différents couler désolé
un peu après concernant a vu ben tu es
la fun et la flore il voulait voir un
peu baleine n'a pas trouvé et là quand
on était là comme ça
salut allez ciao
mon pays comment il est
la Réunion s'amène
nous verrez que la même un peu de
respect pour mon pays vraiment d'après
depuis son lit bout de la terre dans le
paradis pour comprendre pour un de mon
pays
la réunion nous les la même mais mon
pays comment il est la réunion
s'améliorer la mer la peine respect pour
mon pays vraiment d'après des bisous
et ça a été réalisé par le NF et nous
départons nous contrôle pour voir
comment il est pour voir la sécurité
plus ou moins pour le pour le randonneur
donc là les aménagements que nous leur
fait là
sur place ah ok d'accord
même au cœur de pas donc on peut pas
faire les travaux n'importe comment donc
tout le matériau l'effet sur place
directement ok ben dis moi un petit peu
la leçon entier de la vas-y commence
tout ça il finit en fait le sentier des
laves nous a dit il sort depuis basse
Valley l'idée c'est de dire de base
vallée Saint-Philippe jusqu'à
Sainte-Rose avec justement des des
panneaux d'interprétation pour l'instant
on a que des on va dire la signalétique
directionnelle pour orienter tout ce qui
dit les randonneurs mais après nous on
aura aussi des aménagements
spécifique sur les coulées de lave et
puis ça après c'est tout un chacun le
respect maintenant après de la
biodiversité nous voit que on en a des
arbres tout autour donc on a des
histoires on a des endémiques et tout
donc tout ça il faut mérite un respect
et c'est pour ça le département le
département 1000 litres justement pour
préserver ces zones ces zones que les
gens qui découvrent et qui découvrent en
laissant propre après par la suite aussi
c'est un beau message voilà ok bon en
tout cas merci bien il était chouette on
a trouvé moi même cocher par là ok pas
de souci merci Ciao
et ben voilà au bout de deux heures de
marche nous on a fini notre balade sur
le sentier des laves et nous ça arrive
sur un parking alors il faut savoir que
dans plusieurs entrées et plusieurs
sorties qui permettent de découvre le
sentier des larves et de découvrir aussi
les plusieurs coulés que l’œil et ça les
vrais mon gars écoutez la Réunion on a
gagné
et tout ça rendez-vous dans la prochaine
épisode de l'émission à nous cette fois
ci ne sera dans la communauté Saint-Paul
et nous voir les visites le bassin vital
Gaïa la semaine natation
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]